et
revenir en octobre pour la première fois
depuis six ans les enfants vont
apprendre à lire sans redouter le bruit
des sirènes ou le fracas des bombes
il faut que ce petit monde grandissent
et s'instruisent en fait
spectacle toujours le même et toujours
nouveau le premier jour c'est
merveilleux comme on est sage mais
maxime les plus sévères sont avalés avec
le sourire
et
rentré de paix mais encore rentré de
crise lors s'ouvre at on délivre des
crayons des cahiers et des souliers
avec le 1er octobre écoliers collégiens
et lycéens ont pris ou repris le chemin
de l'école au milieu d'un optimisme plus
ou moins mitigés
jusqu'au dernier moment certains ont pu
encore craindre ou espérer qu'on ne les
prendrait pas faute de place car dans ce
domaine comme dans l'autre la crise du
logement s'est il s'agit de caves et 7
millions d'élèves
le sixième de la population française va
à l'école mais tout le monde sera
acceptée en se serrant un peu il est bon
à côté des anciens bâtiments et en
attendant que les nouveaux soit achevé
on a ouvert des écoles provisoire c'est
ainsi que dans paris plusieurs écoles ou
lycées ont maintenant une ou plusieurs
annexes
de plus on a mis en place des classes
préfabriquées malgré l'accroissement
considérable des effectifs tous les
enfants iront à l'école et souhaitons
que les solutions provisoires ne soit
que provisoire
et
l'aube n'aurait pas dû avoir ce matin là
la même banalité que les autres matin il
est vrai que le grand événement qui
devait se produire sur le territoire des
treize académies de la zone à échappa
aux populations laborieuses
il concernait pourtant près du quart des
habitants
la première vague des 12 millions de
français d'âge scolaire allait prendre
le chemin de l'école un chemin oublié
depuis de longs mois
pas de problème de logement cependant
cette année malgré trois cent soixante
dix mille élèves de plus le retard en
bâtiment a été rattrapé reste le cas des
enfants à ce frein pour la première fois
à la prolongation de la scolarité de 14
à 16 ans le problème est nouveau et il
faudra occuper ses 130 mille élèves
prolongée et puis il y à lait maternel
non
on a tout dit sur le premier jour de
classe
le premier contact avec l'école l'entrée
dans la condition écolière c'est la
première vraie mutation dans la vie d'un
enfant
le deuxième sera et c'est pourquoi la
scène se joue parfois comme un petit
drame en trois actes ou lever de rideau
de 8h30
et
e
on
le nombre d'enfants de 3 à 5 ans ne
cesse d'augmenter
cette année il va falloir faire front à
la vague de 2 millions de petits
écoliers et trouver le moyen de les
faire sourire il y a beaucoup de mères
sans doute ce jour là qu'ils se sont
sentis to tatou orpheline d'enfants
on est obligés
le savoir et de beaucoup la portion la
plus considérable du bonheur sophocle
à
oh
alors je suis sûr que comme moi comme de
très nombreux parents vous avez rêvé un
jour d'être petit oiseau est de voir
comment votre fille votre garçon a vécu
sa première matinée de classe bien pire
champetier et jacques aubertin ont été
pour vous ces petits oiseaux
ils n'ont pas voulu faire de
sentimentalisme leur diagnostic vous le
verrez et simplement clinique mais il
est fascinant
ben hamouda
oui
malgré les apparences l'intégration à la
classe va se faire très vite
la maîtresse cherche à établir un
premier contact symbolique les moins
timides accepte l'engagement mais les
réticences sont nombreuses sans cri sans
larmes sept enfants s'est tout de suite
en fermé sur lui-même il faudra sans
doute plusieurs jours pour l'apprivoiser
l'attrait de la nouveauté commence à
faire son effet
plus à l'aise les petits curieux partent
à la découverte de la classe ils
prennent possession des lieux
l'unité du groupe se forme spontanément
autour des pinceaux et des couleurs
chacun apporte sa contribution à
l'oeuvre collective la classe sous
d'elle-même sans l'aide de la maîtresse
c'est gribouillis sont à l'image de la
classe qui se cherchent et se trouve la
communication s'établit par gestes cris
bruit ou regard mais deux heures a fait
la rentrée aucune parole n'a été
échangée
on sent que les dernières défenses sont
sur le point de tomber pendant la
récréation les solitaires et les timides
gravitent autour de la maîtresse
ces échanges de coups sont aussi une
façon de se mesurer et de se connaître
oui
après la récréation une nouvelle étape
est franchie on se parle leurs petits
groupes le dialogue s'instaure autour
des futurs leaders de la classe juste
avant l'arrivée des moments l'intimité
du groupe et créer la nouvelle classe
est né
la fille que je voulais avec les
campeurs demain